what is the image of the polygon below  after the translation is capital T with  the subscript 5 comma 2 so that means  let's translate 5 in the horizontal  direction and 2 in the vertical  direction so let's do that so I'm going  to focus on this point right over here  so that point is at the point 3 comma 3  if I want to translate 5 in the  horizontal direction that the x value is  going to get to 8 so the exercise is  going to 1 2 3 4 5 and then we want to  increase the Y value by 2 1 2 let's  check our answer let's do a couple more  of this so that was a lot of fun so here  we need to shift it by negative 8 in the  horizontal direction so this one right  over here it's x value is zero so we  need to go essentially negative 8  negative 1 negative 2 or move to the  left 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and then we have to  move it down by 2 so we have to move  down 1 move down 2 and we're done